皆さん福袋とかよく開けますでしょうかあのお正月とかのイメージが強いと思うんです
よ福袋とかってねせが意外とお正月以外にも服ブックの
意外と保証髪以外の福袋っていうとは売っておりまして
あのポケモンの新作海域を問いただせ行ったんですけどもそちらで見つけてきました
ギューンで会ブースで傘がすごいんですけども男の声
音女の子用がありますウーパー black friday
ウィザーラッキーパー梱包んラッキーバッグギャーというなんかとへ猿ってや珍しい
こんなワケわかんない期間にこんなでかい福袋が売っておりましたので買わせて
いただきました
これたぶんすごいんですよそもそも分フライデーって何なんだろうっていうプレミアム
フライデーとか結構話題になってたんですけど
おブラックフライデーって何やろうと思って
特に何も調べていませんでもそういう効果がありましてここを移しておくね
学ブルー衝撃10 days 対象の商品全品50%オフ半額以上安いんですよ
おもちゃがやっぱいマジびびった今日普通にはのお店に行ったんですけども結構この2
パーブラックフライデーのラップバックスはボイブラック
バッジャーを買ってるあの防犯傘が多かったのでうわすげーなーと思って見れました何
入ってるかわかんないっていうのやっぱ楽しみなんてそういう楽しみ方もあるかなと
思いました
代々木第開けておきましょうまず防衛いただけますねでかい同じで本当にデカイ女じゃ
んがなんと3000円でございますめっちゃ安い
つまり50パー4だとしても少なくとも6000円ぐらいのものが入っているという
計算になりますオートベース上げていきましょうサーモン缶なんやとーまね ev
買えたので良かったです可愛いですよ
[拍手]
えっなんかアレなんだえっええっ
またすごいとも狙ってきたのコレ複数ローデスも苦労の進化ですねポケモンです
福0福ずローカーボ木1-1進化がちょっとなんかやっぱ微妙なところなんですよね
やっぱ可愛い第二審がかっこいい台に進化みたいなところですよ
スペスロウが入ってましたかわいそうにアーモンド言いますよなんだこれええ
ウルトラ海津デラックスベリアル融合ずサンダーキラー
得るドラマの敵キャラですね
いろんなやまだわからないですよまだわからないあった
えっ
熱愛って本当にリラックス妖怪ポッドリラックス妖怪ポッドな妖怪ウォッチのなんか
メダルに対応したりなんかよくわかんないんですねこれとかもなくついちゃったな気が
するな
まだまだありますよ水ミニョンのこれくダブルデラックスセットあー見ぬふりだビルド
ラビットターン
フォームこれすげえなんか凄そうだなおおーなんで半分だけへ半分しか
合体するのかお魚次々が合体して仮面ライダーになっちまいました
お得ねーああいろんなのですから混ざってるポケモンにウルトラマンに仮面ライダーに
業界ウォッチ得て皆様
いやーこれは男でも喜びますがそれでまだ入ってましたよ
あれで猛追方へスターウォーズダースねーガーディアンですねこれなんか俺プラ事好き
な人にあげたりした方がいいんだなちょっと校
そしてラストでちょっとはい
また妖怪月デラックス妖怪チェーンソードにそのチェーンソーなんて使っての妖怪
ウォッ2個はこれとこれがなくがっかりするんだろうなぁせいぜいそうだ
hey
グッチだすごいすごいすごいねこれとなんかこれを組み合わせる使うみたいな感じです
どうやってこうやって
大敵で男の子こんな感じでしたねでこれすごくね結構まずやすいよぶっ壊れ金額では
今度も何から何まで pokemon all ドラマーの仮面ライダースターンを
妖怪乙すぎる網羅されてますや個人的にはベイブレードとか入ってたらもっとはついい
なと思った今日や
これで30マジで凄いなのかねやっぱ男の子っていうのもあるんでちょっと
停車終わりましたじゃあ女の子あげて
いきましょう俺の経験ゾーンで女がこの中にも出た嬉しいのが入ってるんでは
たまごっちとか言ってたらめっちゃテンション上がりますからねで分けていきますはい
何ロゼットメイク専用ヘアアクセサリーセットですかも可愛いですね
あらあああこれもゼロから作るのねはい編ね女の幸をと馬場を開けて遊ぶだけみたいな
感じですけど女加工作るのが好きなんだねリボンリボンがついて持ってこんな可愛いの
ができるんだ
者には難しいかなあー
かわいい移動できますよ
なぜつじゃないかははい3つを言っての
をまずはーでは行っても女の子はやったねこういうだからヘアーメイクアクセサリーと
は喜ぶのかもしれないですねまだ3年ちょっと引きました
次行きましょうただちゃま後ちょっと買ったらティナ入ったね秘密のコパポカーンと
ヒートマフラーの神様
いやごめんよーねちょっとこういうのわかんないんだろうなんだけど全然ポかリンの姫
と思いますよあったかそうな名前並べても卵が付いてるからここにこうやって出て
[音楽]
ありがとうございました夫じゃ思次行きましょうやばいだから俺が断然男の子用か
楽しい車ところはい何どんなんだな
柘植高レア嬉しいなファイティングドディのロボフィッシュコーヒーポットセット
すげえなんか電池いれば水中で泳ぐみたいなやつです高齢は2位嬉しいぞっていうふう
にこのドリーの水槽ってことでしょ
ドーリー
鳥姫水入れてきます
[音楽]
ターンとリーは置いといて次に行きましょうまだありますよはいはーい
さっきのだったっていうのは髪の毛につける端で海馬んだサーヤ e 年で女の子は
可愛くだけどさー俺たち男は資源だよあもんなのが嬉しいんでしょうねませんリボン
アクセサリーが作れるらしいですね俺は絶対つくんです
なっていきますよハンドソープハンドソープのここ高く
リニック北京この子こだまっていうのが人気なのかなぁ
もうめっちゃ色々入ってる夜行ネオちょっとしんどいぜ生き物あって生き物を大まさか
もうこれややばいぞこれ
北港家だけあってっ息もだろランもうここ玉たちはどこへ行ったやまあここだまだて
なしでやるって事方っていうのはこちら復活させるしかないねえソープ桃姫トッポたん
だけど
ですけどこのことは学校に行かせてあげましょう
楽しいですね the last なんだったという
はい
ミラクルタクトアイドルかけの先進ミラクル tunes
めくるた口調でございますすごいすごい
すごいぞおおミラ桁きたらすごいすごいすごいさんこれ
電池がねーなー様子天地持ってきたはこれでどんな音が奏でるの
いって理由はねぇ
底あっとチャップ0 z スレペ
[音楽]
はぁ
ちゃんとつければ
[音楽]
あやしてやります